نعم
[موسيقى]
ام
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الا يحاول
اعداء الثوره في الداخل والخارج
صوم له بلدان الربيع العربي وافشال ثورتها
عن طريق تفجير الصراع بين الاسلاميين
وخصومهم الا يبدو ذلك واضحا في مصر وتونس
اليس المطلوب الانتقام من الثوراه بضرب
الطوارئ بعضهم ببعض اليس خصوم الاسلاميين
مسؤولين ومتواطئين مع قوى داخليه وخارجيه
لازاحه الاسلاميين عن المشهد السياسي
الم يكن زعيم حزب غد الثوره ايمن نور على
حق عندما قال ان مصر تحترق امام اعيننا
ونحن مشغولون في تصفيه صراعات داخليه الا
يحاولون تكرار المشهد المصري بحذافيره في
تونس من خلال اشعال النار بين حزب النهضه
الحاكم وحكومه او خصومهم من اليساريين
والعلمانيين
الا يعلم خصوم الاسلاميين انهم مجرد ادوات
يستخدمها اعداء الثورات في الداخل والخارج
لتحويل بلدان الربيع العربي الى جحيم
لكن في المقابل لماذا لا نقول ان ما يحدث
في مصر وتونس مثلا تصحيح لمسار الثوره بعد
ان اختطافها الاسلاميون اليس الاسلاميون
مسؤولين عن استفزاز قطاعات شعبيه واسعه
بعد ان يستاثروا بالساحه بعد التوراه
لماذا نتهم خصوم الاسلاميين بتفجير الصراع
مع الاسلاميين اذا كان الاسلاميون انفسهم
اخفقوا في استعمال في خصومهم ومشاركتهم في
حصاد الثورات اليس من السقف تصوير المعركه
في مصر بين علمانيين واسلاميين
لم يخرج الى الميادين مئات الالوف من
المصريين لاسقاط حكومه الرئيس مرسي اليست
حكومه النهضه في تونس مسؤوله عن الامن في
البلاد فلماذا تتكرر عمليات اغتيال
المعارضين لماذا لا نعتبر الحراك السياسيه
في مصر وتونس نتيجه طبيعيه وصحيه
للديمقراطيه الناشئه في بلدان الربيع
العربي اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
الناشط السياسي رئيس المنتدى المصري في
بريطانيا الدكتور هاني لبيب وعلى الناشط
اه اشرف السعد النشاط السياسي ايضا اشرف
الساعه نبدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان تفجير الصراع بين
الاسلاميين والعلمانيين او الاسلاميين
وخصومهم في العالم العربي هدفه افشال
الربيع العربي واحد وتسعين فاصله سبعه نعم
ثمانيه فاصله ثلاثه لا لو بدات معك بهذه
النتيجه دكتور هاني الدين يمكن قرارها غلط
في البدايه دكتور هاني ما الذي يجعل هذه
النسبه العاليه من المصوتين اكثر من واحد
وتسعين بالمائه يعتقدون ان ما يحصل الان
في بعض بلدان العراق الربيع العربي وخاصه
في مصر وتونس هو محاوله مفضوحه لضرب
الاسلاميين بخصومهم
لافشال الربيع العربي ولضرب اه الثورات
والانتقام من الثورات هناك محاوله في
الشرق الاوسط الان حيث يوجد طوائف يضربون
الطوائف بعضها ببعض حيث لا يوجد طوائف كما
هو الحال في مصر وتونس وحتى في تركيا
يحاولون تفجير الصراع بين العلمانيين
والاسلاميين لماذا هناك نسبه كبيره تؤمن
بهذا الاتجاه يعني في البدايه طبعا الكل
ينظر الموضوع من منظور اسلاميين وغير
اسلاميين لكن انا ارى ان اذا نظرت الى
الموضوع من زاويه اخرى وهي من هم اصحاب
المبادئ وغير اصحاب المبادئ لان احنا تنظر
في تعريف العلمانيين والليبراليين تجد
انهم يؤمنون ب مؤسسات الدوله والدستوريه و
بالحريه وبال اه القنوات الفضائيه ال
الاعلام ويكون بالحريه والمساواه كلها اذا
طبقت هذه الاشياء على كثير ممن يدعون انهم
ليبراليين وعلمانيين في ا وطنيا لا تجد هم
اصلا لكن هم لهم اصحاب منافع معينه ولكن
ليس مقتنعين بهم كما ان هناك فصيل اخر من
الشرعيه والدستوريه ومؤمنين به فالقضيه
حينها تنظر مثلا في ليبيا هذا الامر مختلف
في ليبيا الاغلبيه الموجوده ليست اسلاميه
بل على العكس ليس له الى سبعه عشر مقعد
برلمان فيها لكن مع ذلك يحدث عمليات
اغتيال عبد السلام المسماري تم اغتياله
وهو من الليبراليين وتم اغتيال ايضا الشيخ
محمد بن عثمان وهو من الاخوان المسلمين
منذ اربع شهور ولم تقم الدنيا له مع ان
الحكومه الاصليه الموجوده في ليبيا فيه
اصلها كلها هي حكومه ليبراليه وليست
القضيه كلها انه لا بد من احداث هذا النوع
بالاستفاده من الناس ممن ليس عندهم مبادئ
فاليوم عندهم بالحريات غدا يكفر به اليوم
التظاهر حق حق التظاهر اليوم الصناديق هي
الطريق لاقتراع القوي يفرض الصناديق هؤلاء
ليسوا لا اظن فهم لا علمانيين ولا برايي
ان ما اسميهم اناس عديمه اصحاب المصالح طب
ما يحدث الان في في في في مصر وفي في مصر
تحديدا اين يتجه هذا الله هل يتجه ايضا في
ما الذي يحدث في مصر هل هناك محاوله فعلا
لافشال الثوره من خلال تسليط بعض الجهات
على الاسلاميين وخلق هذه الفوضى يعني
اعتقد انه منذ البدايه ان يكون هناك اتجاه
عام ضد ال ال المسؤولين في الدوله ايا كان
المسؤولين حين كان المجلس العسكري موجود
كانت المظاهرات تمشي في ال مصر الطالب
باسقاط حكم العسكر ثم ان تولد جميع
الحكومات في ايام حكم ال ال المجلس
العسكري كان الكل ينتقذ الطبيعي بعد
الثورات ان اي انسان سيكون في السلطه سوف
يكون معرض لان لكل هذه الانتقادات ويطلب
منهم ان تنشمل الاسلاميين تحديدا كان
ينتقل يعني ما الذي يحدث الاسلاميين في
مصر يعني هذه القضيه في ان الاسلاميين
جميعهم اقصائهم الى اقصائهم حتى بما كانوا
يكفرون بالديمقراطيه و ممن كانوا يعتنقون
العنف الجميع قدموا الى صناديق الاقتراع
توافقوا على الحل الذي يمكن ان تمشي الى
الامام ثم اتينا بهذا الانقلاب العسكري
الذي حدث والذي اطاحه بكل شيء في الامر
فيه يعني مهما كان الخلاف بين الاسلاميين
وصولهم الى اشياء سياسيه ممكن الحديث فيها
اما ادخال العسكر مره اخرى في العمليه
السياسيه هذا ما كنا نحاول دائما ان سيد
سعد كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
هناك من يرى ان هناك ايد او ايادي خفيه
اذا صح التعبير تعمل الان على ضرب الثوار
في اكثر من بلد عربي بعضهم ببعض يعني هناك
محاولات صومله محاولات افغان مفضوحه في
مصر الان في تونس من خلال ضرب الثوار
القدامى بعضهم ببعض كما حصل تماما بها
افغان انت تعلم ال المجاهدون الافغان في
افغانستان
بعدما انتصروا على السوفيات ما الذي حدث
بدؤوا يتصارعون فيما بينهم فذهبت العمر
الاسلاميين فذهبت روح الامه الاسلاميه
يعني الاسلاميين او غير اسلاميين هم اطراف
الصراع
الاسلاميه طيب ماشي الان
الا تعتقد ان هناك الان تامر او ت امرا
واضحا على الاسلاميين من خلال العسكر ومن
خلال التيارات الاخرى في مصر مثلا لا هو
هو في الشكل
انما هي هي زي ما كان فيه في محاوله العدل
العدل او او او لاسترداد ما ما ما سلكوا
من الشعب طبعا طبعا انت بتقول خصومهم
خصومه تيار راح يتكلم عن الاداره طبعا
حنان انا مش كافر البطوله الاسلاميين
معناه ان احنا انا ما نحنا والله يكون
ان ان ان اللي بيعرف انما هؤلاء هؤلاء
الغمه على السلطه دون اصبح خمسه وثمانين
سنه من الشعب المصري
كون واحد وثمانين خمسه وثمانين في المائه
من الشعب المصري خصوم هذا هذا ال هذا ال
هذا الفريق الذي جاء
صرف المصريين بل بالعكس تتفرع الى الدول
العربيه
بعد داخل الدول العربيه
قلوب صفوف ال العائلات هناك
يعني ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
الشيطان يريدوا ان يوقع بينكم العداوه فشل
والله العظيم ده استطاع
الدكتور محمد عندما تولى الحكم استطاع
بجداره معرفش
المصريين في ثاني اقل من ثانيه ولم لم
يبقى له حبيب على الخدمات ال المصريين
المصريين
باعمالهم فيما عادل فيما عاد اللي اللي
هما اه متعاطفين او عندهم نفس الفكره او
مظلومين بافكار الثانيه من طبعا التعارف
هؤلاء الناس خلقوا
في هذه السنه لم يستطع اي فصيل في الدنيا
ان يخلقوا لولا الله عز وجل
يحكمون هذه السنه وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
الجيش لان بلا جيش مصر احد عناصر هذا هو
عرضه مصر وشرف مصر وكل من يتكلم عن شرع عن
كل من يلمح ان كلمه
الانقلاب
الى الانقلاب
هذا الانقلاب اول مره في حياتي الشعب
ثمانين في المائه من الشعب المصري يطلب من
الجيش
[موسيقى]
مخطوفين
يا راجل احنا انا انا الساعه الدين ثلاثين
ثانيه انا اشرف الساعه الساعه خمسه
الثمانينات
يضربونا بقولنا بس فقط لا يرضى جماعه اكثر
من مليار يصوت
بالوقت واللحيه الناس في المتدينين الان
هم طلبوا متدينين اصبح يا راجل السيده
اللي كانت بالليل
عشان بتحترم فيه لانه عارفه
كل اطياف الشعب الان هؤلاء هؤلاء الناس
الان جعلوا الاسلام شكل المسلم
يكون للناس هؤلاء استطاعوا
كيف اذن المشكله ليست
محاوله لضرب او لتسليط اذا صح التعبير
خصوم الاسلاميين على الاسلاميين لافشال
الثورات اول اه يعني لتحويل بلدان الربيع
العربي الى جحيم بل المشكله في الدرجه
الاولى كما يقول لك سيد سعد هي في
الاسلاميين انفسهم كيف ترد ياريت تكلمت
شويه الدبلوماسيه
انا راح يتكلم عنها
يعني بدايه
المحددات لما نضعها في البدايه نستريح
فيها اذا كان حقيقه خمسه وثمانين في
المائه من الشعب المصري راضي عن الحكومه
او عن الرئاسه كان عندهم من السور
يستطيعون الذهاب اليها بهذا الاتفاق خمسين
في المائه ويغير
لا لا لا
فبالتالي كان يستطيع ان ياخذ هذا الامر
لكن
الجيش في هذا الموضوع لابد ان نقولها مره
واثنين
سيدي
عم بسالك انا عندما تكلمنا قلت لي انه
هناك محاوله ومؤامره ودينيه
الان
والله احنا بالخط النقاط على الحروف يعني
انت تريد ان تضع امور فيها انا بسالك فيها
من وجهه نظر فيها انت تقول الاسلاميون هم
السنه والمشكله
انا ليس عندي مشكله فليكن الاسلاميون عنده
مشكله اداره الدوله بطريقه خاطئه فبالتالي
يتم تغييرهم عن طريق ايضا العرف ال ميثاق
العهد الذي اخذ
جاء الدكتور محمد مرسي عبر انتخابات شرعيه
فيها القضيه الرئيسيه في عين الاشرف
بيعتبر انه حكم العسكر لمده ثلاثين سنه
وستين سنه موجودين في مصر حكم شرعي وموجود
حتى يفهم المشاهد عن اي خلفيه نتكلم
وبالتالي احنا نتكلم من هذه القضيه اقول
نحن ب انا ب صناديق بشرعيه شعبيه قليله
كانت ام كثيره وكاننا ممكن ان نذهب بيقول
اي مشكله وبدون اي احد الشعب لو خرجنا
ايضا من نفس الباب الموجود فيه فمن هنا
نقول جواز الجيش بالسلطه باطل يا عتريس من
فؤاده باطل قام بها الاستاذ او ممن
يحاولون او البعض او قام وزير الازهر ومن
باب والله يعطيه الرسول المحللين
الذي
ماذا يريد خصوم الاسلاميين من مصر يا سيدي
الفاضل المراد هو في ان تتفتت الوحده
المصريه الموجوده هذا امر
هو المسؤول عن ذلك يسال عنه جميع الاطراف
التي سعت الى احداث هذا الامر فيه لا الوم
الاعداء الاسلاميين وحده ولكن اقول ان
هناك اخطاء من الاسلاميين في هذا الامر
لكنه هناك تحالف خارجي واقليمي لا يجب ان
ننكر اطلاقا موجود على الساحه برد من
الدول الاقليميه ومن الخارج في دعم هذا
الانقلاب واعطاء طائله في هذه الفتره هذا
امر معروف
العربيه الموجوده هذه القضيه كلها في هذه
النقطه ولذلك كما قلنا الامر في ليبيا
الاسلاميه السلطه ومحاوله اجهاض في
السلطه
الاغلبيه كذلك المجلس الوطني فيها
تسعه وعشرين ومع ذلك
بهذا العمل
اه
في ليبيا وغيرها هذه الحرب الطريق موجوده
داخل هذه الدول
هذه الثورات
محاولات
واحد واحد من الاخوان وبين
واحد الجمهوريه
المظاهرات
بس دقيقه دقيقه بس دقيقه طب انت لماذا
تحاول ان تقفز فوق الحقائق التاريخ وفوق
كل
الم ياتوا الى السلطه عن طريق صناديق
الاقتراع باصوات اكثر من واحد وخمسين
بالمائه من الشعب المصري
اعيد السؤال بطريقه اخرى
يعني اليس هناك
محاوله مكشوفه مفضوحه
عندما نسمع عندما نسمع الدكتور ايمن نور
يقول بالامس بالحرف الواحد مصر تحترق امام
اعيننا ونحن مشغولون بتصفيه خلافاتنا من
المسؤول عن ضرب الاسلاميين بخصومهم من
المسؤول عن تطبيق من المسؤول عن تسليط او
عن شيطنه الاسلاميين في مصر
الاسلاميين في تونس في الاماكن التي فيها
الاسلاميه
والله العظيم انا بتكلم ان احنا
اي دوله عربيه
اللي بيحكوها عسكري وبعيده
اسرائيل
اللي بيعمل الشيخ اسرائيل
على هذه
النقطه
ليس هناك مؤامره وليس هناك محاوله ل صولات
مصر او افغان اه مصر او عرقله مصر او
لبنان مصر ليس هناك محاوله لكل ذلك
المسؤول الاول والاخير عن ما يحدث من فوضى
منتشره في بلدان الربيع العربي في مصر في
تونس هم الاسلاميون انفسهم هم المسؤولون
عن هذا التشرذم هم الذين ادوا بالبلاد الى
هذه الفوضى الى هذا الشرخ الكبير داخل
المجتمع كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
بدايه فيها الانقسام طبيعي جدا ان يكون
موجود عقب الثوره الانقسام داخل المجتمع
المصري لم يبدا بتولي الدكتور محمد جميل
كان موجودا من قبل وكان ايها المجلس
العسكري والمجلس وعلى فكره لابد ان نفرق
بين قياده الجيش وبين الجيش قلنا نفخر
بارتداء دراسه ولنا اقارب اهل داخل الامر
وحينما نتكلم في المسائل السياسيه قياده
سياسيه للجيش اخذت قرارات نحن عظيمين عنها
فلا احد يريد تفتيت الجيش ولا احد يتحدث
عن الجيش ان يجري وعمق وهو يهم وانا عامي
في قوات المساله احلها الله يرحمه نتكلم
عنه اذا ب ليش ناخذ هذه الامور نحن لدينا
امور واضحه وضوح الشمس هذه الامور وهي ان
تدخل بهذه الطريقه الجيش في هذه العمليه
افسدها دخلنا الى الانتخابات كلنا منقسمين
نعم ولا الاستفتاء الدستوري كان هناك
انقسام دخلنا حتى الانتخابات البرلمانيه
كانت هناك انقساما دخلنا الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه حتى الفريق احمد شفيق نفسه وحتى
الليبراليين انفسهم لم يتفقوا على مرشح
واحد للدخول به ولا كذلك الاسلاميين في
حاله ال ال ال الافتراض بعد الثورات هذا
امر محمود وليس اشكاليه الاشكاليه ان
يحاول اي طرف خيط ان الطرف الاخر في هذا
ما يحدث وهذا ما يحدث
في اي دوله في العالم يحدث هذه التوفيق
للتهمه السياسيه واه ال التي يحكم زعماء
المعارضه احد يتكلم حتى مفتوح وليس من
الاخوه حروب الامن بيقول التلفزيون المصري
في برنامج المشهد اليوم يقال انه
التلفزيون لا احد يستطيع ان يتكلم في
الدوله اللي ما تريده الاداره العسكريه
الموجود حاليا اكثر من اربعمائه شهيد في
خلال شهر واحد الف وثمانمائه
اه معتقل
هل هذه الحريات التي بشر بها ان هذه
الاداره والفرق بين يكون انسان في العسكر
وخرج من العسكر ويقول الدوله اهلا ما عندي
مشكله لكن حين يرتدي العسكري في وظيفته
الاساسيه هي حمايه هذا الوطن وحمايه
لم يكن من الذي يحاول الانتقام من الثوره
في مصر يعني هذه هذا هو ما اقوله لا يمكن
لاي طرف خارجي ان ينجح في الانتقام من
الطلبه في مصر لولا وجود اشخاص في مصر هذه
الايادي التي لا تريد ان تعترف باي
والمتمثل في
يا اخي لانه حتى في ميدان الردع هناك
اسلامي وهاي القنديل ليس من الاسلاميين
ليس من الاسلاميين اي من الاسلاميين
القضيه ليست اسلاميين وغير اسلاميين اصحاب
مبادئ
اذن الديني المبادئ نعم هم الذين الان
ينخرطون هم الان
سيطره الاخوان شيطان ت الاعداء اقصاء
النداء بال بال اقتحام والقتل الفرح
والحدود لسان لدماء المصريين ول تكميم
الحريات هؤلاء يا اخي الكريم كانوا يقولون
على الدكتور محمد في عصر في جميع قنوات ما
لا يقال زيد في القمر ومع ذلك لا يتحملوا
فقط خمس سنوات من اصل خمسين فضائيه ان
تخرج ان تتكلم وانتشر بغض النظر الاخرى
لانه ليس لديهم حجه ولا منطق في النهايه
فبالتالي هؤلاء هذه هي سلاحهم وهذا مبدا
هم ونقل نحن لذلك الوقوف اليوم ليس من اجل
موسى وليس من اجل شيء انا اقول اين
الشرعيه الدستوريه كان ال م ما قاله
الفريق السيسي حينما اعلن الانقلاب لا
يختلف عن ما قاله الدكتور مقابل ثمانيه
واربعين ساعه سوى في قاله الدكتور بوش بل
حتى ان احمد فهمي رئيس مجلس الشوري قال ان
الرئيس بوش يوافق على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المبكره بعد اربع شهور عاقب انتخابات مجلس
الشعب فقال ها الفريق السياسي انا اوافق
على هذا ما في خمسطاشر يوم الان يعني اذا
المطروحه بما فيها تغيير الرئاسه قابله
لكن اذن الى الحل الدستوري لا تجعل الشعب
المصري بعد ان اعلنته في صندوق الانتخاب
بعد مقاطعه دامت ستين عاما يذهب اليها
ويعطي صوره تقول له كل اصواتها بالدستور
كل شيء والامر الذي يستطيع ان احد ان يقام
عليه لو فرض المدينه غدا وذهبوا الى
انتخابات واجهه رئيس اخر اي كان اسمه ولم
يرضى عنه الجيش و قم القلب ما هو الضمان
والامان حتى القانوني في الدستور يلغى
الدستور في حد ذاته نحن نريد لهذا الشعب
هيبته ليست القضيه من يحكم ولا السلطه كما
يقول اشرف ولكن القضيه ان يكون هناك ميثاق
اذا كنا في مباراه كره القدم بين فريقين
فلابد ان يكون هناك حاكم في النهايه فيه
اما ان تقول ان الحاكم والفريق في اتجاه
اخر انتفى في قواعد اللعبه الجهود في
الموضوع كيف يحدث عن طريق الصناديق لا
الطريق الشارع الشارع دلوقت المشكله يعني
ميداني تحرير يا اخي اكبر شريان في مسرح
ان ما يغلق لمده عام بالكامل ليس فيه
اشكاليه اما اذا راجع على الناس المرور في
مشكله يعني احنا يقول الكاتب اشياء كثيره
في نفس الوقت هل تستطيع ان تنكر هل تستطيع
ان تنكر بان الاسلاميين اثبتوا بانهم
الوحيدون بعد الثورات العربيه
اه المؤمنون ب صناديق الاقتراع وبال لعبه
الديمقراطيه على عكس كل خصومهم من
العلمانيين والليبراليين
الدقيقه والعسكر وكل ذلك
طيب هم قالوا نحن ن نحتكم الى صناديق
الاقتراع اعدائهم وخصومهم
لا يريدون صناديق الاقتراع يريدون المنطقه
يريدون حتى لو ادى ذلك الى تفتيت مصر ايضا
في تونس لو سمعت الى الغنوشي بالامس يقول
لك نحن مستعدون للذهاب الى استفتاء ليس
لدينا اي مشكله بهذا الخصوص اذن على العكس
من ذلك ل ونظرتها الى العلمانيين او خصوم
الاسلاميين في تونس وهم من الفلول من
العهد القديم من خارجيين البرازيل كل
هؤلاء لا هم لهم الا اسقاط الاسلاميين
وحتى لو خرجت البلاد
يا خي كيف سقطوا
يعني اذا
ان تنسى ثلاثين عاما او عشرين عاما في
تونس نينو ثلاثه وعشرين عام في تونس من
الخراب والفساد والدمار ومشكلتنا الان في
مصر وفي بلدان الربيع العربي هي
الاسلاميون لماذا هذه الشيء
المشكله كلها ان احنا كان عندنا
لانهم كانوا
الرئيس مبارك ان ارى ان حاجه عنده مستشار
[موسيقى]
اصابها
حركه حماس السوري كان يطلع
خالد مشعل
الثورات العربيه كان يطلع يقول سوريا
الاسد
وانا بشار الاسد
لكن لا كانوا اول من اول خيانات هما اللي
ب يعني اللي ما هؤلاء من الجيش المصري ولا
الجيش المصري الباطل
طنطاوي الرئيس
الرئيس شعبنا مع الشعب لو سمحت
الرئيس مبارك
اللي
اسلاميين هو الوقت هو اللي طلع لو كانوا
حطوها
محمد للناس تنتخب الاسلام ومع ذلك اولمرت
ان او وهو تيار
الطاوله منعرفش اللي بتلاقي او الخيانه
عملوه صاحب اليد
الجاليه اول حاله من انجازات
سعاده الدكتور ما اللي فيه كتاب للدكتور
من انجازات
انت الان وبهذه الكبيره اللي انت تدافع
بطريقه
العلمانيين والليبراليين والى ما هنالك
هؤلاء الملائكه ما عندنا مشكله
العسكري في دول الربيع العربي
بالله العظيم
اللي
ثمانين مليون وتسعين مليون
الشركات
ان الملايين التي يتحدثون عنها التي نزلت
الى الشارع ليست موجوده الا في خيالات
الاعلام المصري المريض
نحن لم يجري اي قياسات والاعداد الملايين
هذه كلياتها لا تعتبر مئات الالاف بالاكثر
من اين لك هذه ال هذه تسعمائه مليون
وعشرين مائه مليون
المصري
البريطاني امريكا
باعطاء الضوء الاخضر للانقلاب العسكري
لصالح اسرائيل مثلما فعلت امريكا من قبل
باعطاء الضوء الاخضر غزو الكويت مما ترتب
عليه انهيار العراق وتدمير جيشها واه يعني
وكنا نتصور ان يكون السياسي قد تعلم من
الا تعتقد ان اولئك الذين انقلبوا على
الاسلاميين وبدؤوا يحاولون يعني خلق فوضى
الساحه المصريه
يؤدون سيذهبون بمصر الى الجحيم
العالم
العالم باكمله قيادات
الامارات والعرب
الجرائم اللي
لماذا نحن نحاول ان نصور الوضع في بلدان
الربيع العربي ان كان في مصر وفي تونس وفي
على انه يعني هناك مؤامره على الاسلاميين
هناك شيطنه للاسلاميين هناك محاوله لحشد
الصفوف وانزال الناس الى الشوارع ضد
الاسلاميين وانه علمانيين ضد اسلاميين
وليبراليين
اسلاميه وانتقلت ضمير وناس مع يعني او
الناس ما عندهم المبادئ الرجل يقول الاخير
هذا الكلام الرجل يقول لك نحن في بلدان
الربيع العربي هذه في حاله تصحيح ثوره في
حاله
استرداد الثوره المشكله المشكله ليست ليست
في تاجيج الصراع بين الاسلاميين وخصومهم
الشارع هو الذي قام ضد الاسلاميين الشارع
الذي يقوم في مصر الشارع الذي يتحرك في
تونس انظر ماذا يفعلون بحركه النهضه انظر
ماذا يفعلون بالاسلاميين في كل مكان
الشارع يفعل هذا لماذا انتم دائما تفكرون
بعقليه المؤامره وهذا الكلام للسيد
الاشراف يعني بدايه الموضوع مش مؤامره
فيها
كل من من يتحدث باسم الشعب لانه انت
حنتكلم عقلاني العام الف لا نقول نحن
نتحدث بالارقام وحينما اقول لك استاذ انها
القضيه وقال لك اعتبر الى خمسه الاف لكن
يجمعهم ف هذا الكلام انا اتفهم ونحن نتكلم
عن ماذا يريد غالبيه الشعب المصري ماذا
يريد الجيش لان الجيش هو الذي يفهم مصلحه
الشعب سواء كان الشعب الاخرى عشر مليون او
ثلاثمائه فاذا خرج غدا بنفس ال اذا خرج
بكره قائد اخر في الجيش وعمل الانقلاب على
الفريق السيسي ثم اطاح به وقال انه يقول
القضايا
سوريا
الافتراض الجدليه نقاش الاستاذ الاشرف
يجلس هنا القضيه الرئيسيه ان يدافع عن
العصر كانت العسكر مبارك كان في المجلس
العسكري
انا بقولو افتراضا
السياسي وواحد ابو الليبراليين
يقول انا ما هو القسم والنظام فيه
نتكلم ان القضيه ليست ولا اعتراض على شخص
بالعكس كان
بطريقه السياسيه يخرج من الجيش بعد انتهاء
مدته يرشح نفسه للرئاسه ويقود مصر الى
الامام ما هي المشكله بكل اشكالها تناقلنا
الجيش المصري ملك المصريين الا يدخل في
السياسه وحين يقول لا يدخل مع طرف كان
بوسع الفريق السياسي ان يصبح
العربيه
حين نتكلم في هذه القضيه بكل بساط القضيه
ليست قضيه شخص انه في الامور
قلنا هذه القضيه القضيه ان يكون لدينا
دستور يحترم وان تكون اليات لتغيير السلطه
تحترم لكن القول بالله عليك حين تخرج جموع
مجابهه لبعضها في الشوارع
الجموع اكثر هل نخرج هل في مثل في فرنسا
الشهر الماضي الحكومه الفرنسيه الشعبيه
تنهي الى ثلاثه وعشرين في المائه فقط هل
لو قسنا رد الفعل في هذا الشارع في الوقت
نقل الحمله الفرنسيه هذه السبت الاول من
كل شهر نخرج العده المظاهرات اللي في
الشوارع والى اكثر نعمل الرئيس من عنده
يعني فيها القضيه نريد للناس
طيب انت لماذا تقوم خصوم الاسلاميين
بانزال الناس الى الشوارع
الاسلاميين الذين
قبل ان قبل ثلاثين يونيو انا كان ينزل
يا سيدي الفاضل كلهم عليهم النزول قلت ان
يتم الانقلاب هنا على الجموع يدعي البعض
انها تمثل الشعب المصري هذه القضيه
الاسرائيليه اما حق في النزول اخذوا اربعه
وعشرين مليون في هذا الرئيس مرسي المنظمه
اكثر من مائه
وخمسين الف القضيه ليست فيه ان تسمح لهم
مفهوم اسمح لي طبعا السيد قنوات قولها
مفقود لم يعتقل واحد من الجماعه معتقد
رئيس مجلس الشعب العربي
النقطه طيب خليني اه
تريد ان تقول ان هناك
يتكرر الان او ينتقل من بلد الى بلد الهدف
منه هو ضرب الثورات في تونس
وبنفس الطريقه برايك يعني في تونس اعتقد
ان هناك بدايه على الرغم من ان الرئيس في
تونس
والذي اعطاءه ثلاثه وخمسين صوت كانت يوم
تسعه وثمانين صوت للحزب النظر فيها القضيه
لم تقم سلطه اطلاقا
ومع ذلك كما قلت الجنود على الحدود في
تونس تم اغتيال الات شخصيتين السياسيين
احراق مقر الحزب النهضه الهدف والهدف
في تونس حزب الماضي لا يمثل في الحكومه
التونسيه مقطوعه الاغلبيه المطلقه سوى
ثلاثين فقط من اجمال الحكومه حزب ال ال ال
العداله والبناء في ليبيا لا يشكل في
الحكومه الى خمس وزارات فقط ولا يشكك في
المجلس الانتقالي التي تسعى القضيه ليست
قضيه من القضيه لابد من تدمير البلد من
الداخل فيها عن طريق هذه الاشياء المصطنعه
كانت عن طريق انقلاب عسكري بها عن طريق
فوضى خلاقه داخل البلد عن طريق عمليات
اغتيالات قد تختلف السبل الموجوده فيها
لكن القضيه لا احد يزايد علينا على الجيش
المصري
الاختلاف السياسي قياده
القضيه
واحد
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء
الناس
السياسي الجيش المصري
الجيش المصري
اطلاق النار عليهم
الجيش نفسه قال نعم اطلقنا النار لان هناك
وليس اطلقوا علينا الاطلاق الجيش عن الناس
كلهم فيها
على هذه النقطه هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان ما
يحدث ضد الاسلاميين بدي ارجع على نفس ال
ضيق الموضوع شويه ما يحدث ضد الاسلاميين
حقيقه ما يحدث
ضد الاسلاميين في مصر من مؤامرات وشيطنه
وكذا وكذا وكذا من الداخل والخارج اه
يتكرر الان في تونس
ما الذي يحدث في تونس لان هذه الاقليه
يعني بيعملوا
بيعملوا
عليه حرام ضد الاسلام
ما الذي
حقيقه
ايام قال لك انه قتلهم الاسلاميه
اللي هو المسؤول
الاسلاميين
لما كان حرب العراق
الاسلام هؤلاء يجب ان تفترض فترات بتونس
من هم هؤلاء خاطئه
والله العظيم
لاننا كنا فيه انما خلي بالك وامريكا
وانا وتعالى وهو ربنا اراده للخطه امريكا
انها تمشي عشان ان هؤلاء الناس ب يخضعون
ابان ستين سنه باسمهم ليس لهم علاقه
خلي بالك الشعب المصري بين الاسلام لا
يعاد الاسلاميه
الشعب المصري
هم يعدون الشعب التونسي
على الاقل
مليار المائه
السبب الثورات اللي في العالم كله الوقت
ابو عزيزي ماشوفناش لا الرئيس اللي كان
ولا احد يعرف
النهضه اللي اللي هو المفروض اللي هو
ال الثورات اللي على الشعوب العربيه
العربيه
الناس الله
اقسم بالله العظيم ان زمان
المصري
دكتور دكتور نقطه مهمه دقيقه طيب لماذا
ايضا نردد نفس الاسطوانه في تونس بان ما
حدث في مصر من مؤامرات وسيناريو ضد
الاسلاميين يتكرر الان ضد الاسلاميين في
تونس الرجل يقول له من المسؤول عن الدوله
في تونس من المسؤول عن الامن في تونس
لماذا هذه عمليات تتكرر عمليات الاغتيال
بحق المعارضين التونسيين من تلوم في هذه
الحاله من تلوم لماذا تلوم الخارج وتقول
انه الخارج والداخل يتامر على الاسلاميين
ولا تلوم الاسلاميين لانهم هم المسؤولون
الان عن الامن في البلاد يعني لا اقول ان
الاسلاميين على اصحاب المبادئ لان فيه
اسلاميين وغيرها هذه النقطه الامر الاول
فيها لماذا حين يموت واحد ليبرالي او
علماني تقوم الدنيا ولا تقعد وقتل عبد
السلام المسماري في ليبيا وكيف اغتيال
يوما المستفيدين فيها لماذا لا نقول ايضا
تم اغتيال الشيخ محمد بن عثمان من قيادات
الاخوان في مصر اه في ليبيا من اربع شهور
محمد
الشيخ
العلمانيين بطريقه انا انا قلت اذا قتل
علماني وقتل اخواني من قتل في مصر في خلال
الفتره السابقه حتى في عصر الرئيس مرسي كم
عدد من ماتوا من الاخوان ومن عادل من
غيرهم في عصر الرئيس مرسي حزبه احرق
مقارنه باحزاب الاخوان كان يعني اذا تحدث
هل لم يكن الاخوان في عصر الرئيس بوش على
الاقل قادرين علاقات لكل هؤلاء بالتغيير
اللي بيحول
لكن هذا النهج لم ياخذوا الاخوان في
حياتهم ولم ياخذوا فيها فبالتالي الى حين
نتكلم عن مساله لا والله ما الاسلاميين
العمل اطلاقا انا لا اعمم اشياء لانه يرخي
اختلاف الواقع حتى اختلاف الوضع في تونس
لم يحكم الجيش في تونس على مدار تاريخه
اطلاقا فيه وكان الخارج المساله السياسيه
برمتها على بعض ان فلا استطيع ان تقول ان
كل لكن اقول هناك سيناريوهات تقترب من
بعضها البعض حين نتحدث عن هذا الامر لكن
البعض يتحدث في واقع الامر انه هناك مخطط
واضح لاشعال الصراعات بين الاسلاميين
وخصومها تركيا خارج الربيع العربي تركيا
لكن الاسلاميين
الاسلاميين
انا خليني اسالك دكتور
[موسيقى]
عبد الوهاب الافندي اليوم في مقاله
عبد الوهاب الافندي فيما قال اليوم اه
يقول بشري غير ساره لخصوم الاسلاميين يقول
لك انا افضل
للشعب الان افضل دعايه للاسلاميين كانت
ولا تزال هي خصومهم اللي انه انتم والجيش
يكفي ان شهرا واحدا من حكم التحالف
العلماني الليبرالي المخابراتي في مصر جعل
حكم مرسي الفاشل يظهر كانه عصر ذهبي بقرب
او يقرب من الخلافه الراشده ف في عهد مرسي
كان الرئيس يشتم ويحقق وكانت مقر الحزب
الحاكم تحرك وتدمر والقصر الرئاسي يحاصر
ومع ذلك لم يكن هناك معتقلون سياسيون ولا
تعذيب والاغلاق للصحفيين
ولم يكن هناك ولم يكن هناك قتل المتظاهرين
السلميين اما ما نشهده في العصر المبارك
الثاني فلا يحتاج الى تحليق يعني انتم من
متى من الاربعه وتسعين وصول الاسلاميين
الذهب الاسلاميين الاسلاميون كل العنقاء
طائر العنقاء
تحت الرماد ثم يظهر كم وغيرها كيف ترد
عليه العالميه على الكلام
بيقول لك من الشعب المصري
الشعب المصري هذا الرجل
هذا هذا موضوع اللازم الذي اقصي الشعب
الجيش لم يتدخل
المنطقه باختصار جمله واحده ماذا تريد ان
تقول له اين تتجه الامور على هذا الحل انا
الامور تتجه نحو الحل الشرعي الدستوري ايا
كان هذا الامر قال ان قصر
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبق لنا اشكر ضيفينا
السيد اشرف السعد و دكتور هندي من التقى
مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين ها
هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم والى اللقاء
العراق
[موسيقى]